[Musique]
s
hop
wild
[Musique]
le
vva
2 la wallonne
d'abord à l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le terrain
les faits
vous regarde et ses créatures sa belle
mort jazz
avec nous ce soir cannes avec françoise
hardy
[Musique]
mélenchon
n'est ce pas
et yvan le bolloc'h
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
bonsoir tous les quatre alors on va
commenter ensemble l'actualité de la
semaine mais d'abord on va parler un
petit peu de votre actualité alors
françoise hardy vous êtes ici ce soir
pour un nouvel album qui s'appelle
parenthèse qu'en disent les astres ça va
être un succès je ne consulte pas les
astres pas pour voter cette coupe ah
ouais maintenant j'ai cassé de
washington parce que 10 marche très bien
et il est très bien ce 10 et 12 duos
donc alors il est duo avec alain delon
jacques dutronc julio iglesias ben
christophers alain souchon rodolphe
burger henri salvador arthur ashe moral
benjamin biolay et hélène grimaud
alors françoise c'est un carton et c'est
mérité parce que quelques pépites dans
ce disque moi j'adore par exemple partir
quand même avec julio iglesias il ya
aussi ce nom voilà ça y est je perds je
stérilet qu'on
[Rires]
donne ne proposait
vient aussi cet enfant que je t'avais
fait de higelin brigitte fontaine avec
rodolphe burger ya que reste-t-il de nos
amours avec bashung et last but not
least la pépite my biotiful damon avec
ben christophers
cema beautiful dit mme obama elle rigole
pas avoir très bonne vanne de penser à
l'extraordinaire section sens c'est vrai
que sur sur chaque album on a en général
une préférence pour une deux trois
chansons et ça c'est pour moi un des uns
des enregistrements les plus beaux
auquel j'aurais eu la chance de
participer donc c'est dû à la qualité de
la chanson qui a été composé créé il ya
quelques années par ben christophers un
jeune artiste britannique et c'est dû
aussi à la qualité de la réalisation qui
est vraiment exceptionnel et qui a été
fait par erick benzi festival à
françoise hardy ça s'appelle taroteurs
et s'il se virent d'huile voilà
le plus dur à convaincre a été soldat
d'heures non le plus dur à convaincre
salvador pas du tout pas du tout
comment ça il est en pleine forme il va
avoir 80 10 ans l'année prochaine
non c'est qu'alain delon vous a autorisé
à le tutoyer mais à la troisième
personne
non je me suis retrouvé dans une
situation surréaliste où il m'avait
demandé de rester à côté de lui pendant
l'enregistrement pour lui tapoter sur
l'épaule chaque fois que c'était à lui
de parler parce qu'en fait on ne chante
tant ce que refusait le réveiller alors
on chante ensemble on dit un texte
très spécial très très spécial et du
tronc comment ça va alors bah ça va
mieux depuis ce duo 1 il a dû booster sa
carrière
comme les normes d'avoir une femme comme
françoise un traîneau des rails très
tolérante annonces et patients ça vous
plairait mélangeant c'est tout le reste
beaucoup à oui moi je suis un admirateur
moi aussi sympathique finalement les
socialistes sympathie pour un soir
alors jean-luc mélenchon justement vous
votre promo on peut directement c'est
pas c'est pas ségolène royal votre promo
un nom ça pas été si vous êtes un
socialiste de gauche c'est incroyable
encore donc voilà socialiste de gauche
emmené un seul plateau
alors au ps en ce moment il ya quoi
comme comité politique exprimée à part
faut qu'elle continue à mettre son
tailleur blanc ségolène on cherchait pas
juste après midi quand même c'est un
phénomène d'hallucinations que les
petits qui entourent ségolène royal je
suis désolé non mais parce que j'ai la
langue qui fixe ou un mais c'est bien
mais oh non mais parce qu'ils avaient un
moment on pouvait plus parler de rien
ouais dès qu'on ouvrait la bouche on se
faisait traiter de machisme et même elle
a quand même largement cancer l'a
sûrement oui mais c'est pas très loyal
parce que une idée vous la combattent et
mais moi je suis un homme j'ai pleuré ce
que j'en suis aussi satisfait pas essayé
de faire c'est christine bravo vous
verrez elle vous dira c'est parce que je
suis une fille alors michel boujenah ya
un truc que je comprends pas avec vous
si vous êtes arrivé en france à l'âge de
11 ans vous avez toujours cet accent
c'est un peu comme comme jane birkin ou
quoi vous le faites exprès mais sur quoi
alors on est sûr qu'elle le fait exprès
je peux vous présentez des garçons qui
sont nés en france de parents qui ont
les mêmes origines que moi et qui ont
encore plus d'accent 1 que des gens qui
sont nés là-bas oui c'est génétique
c'est aussi je suis né là bas j'ai pas
d'accent
oui
alors de nous par le réputé avait le mot
magnifique en tournée et en dvd voilà
alors yvan le bolloc'h vous nous parler
de votre album et de votre groupe qui
s'appelle ma guitare revient là où on
est contents ils vont si vous avez
trouvé enfin un style musical qui
correspond à votre coiffure voilà
le style gitan
le style gitan je l'espère calculateur
n'est pas interdit aux gens du voyage
non il faudra circulé toute municipalité
doit accueillir les gens du voyage voilà
donc
ici
[Musique]
c'était un rituel dans cette émission
bonne nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle alors
augusto pinochet mort dans son lit sans
jamais avoir été jugé bonne nouvelle
mauvaise nouvelle par principe on doit
être meilleur que lui 1 donc on se
réjouit pas de la mort des autres mais
franchement qu'il n'ait pas été jugé
faut il faut voir par quoi sont passés à
cause de ces gens les 3000 personnes qui
ont été assassinées là bas ses ordres
c'est curieux quand j'ai entendu qu'il
était mort j'ai fait wow est super et
l'acte suite j'ai eu un petit pincement
comme si il y avait six revenait ouais
comme s'il revenait derrière pour
m'envoyer dans un stade bon j'imagine
que c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour
vous non plus la mort de pinochet
samy naceri ne touche plus ni à la
cocaïne et à l'alcool ni aux chiites ni
à l'héroïne ni aux attachés de presse ni
au cendrier bonne nouvelle
pour les cendriers pour rigoler non mais
c'est sain c'est un garçon qui peut être
un excellent acteur donc qui prennent
soin de lui vous l'avez vu dans
indigènes formidable c'est une
hallucination des super bon
le 26 décembre le lendemain de noël
charles villeneuve proposera un droit de
savoir spécial comment fonctionnent les
sites de call girls
vous intéressez-vous ça pas du tout pas
du tout cas pas du tout quand je terril
est françoise
il s'agit de la traite d'êtres humains
là dedans donc c'est c'est quelque chose
qui doit pas nous faire marrer j'espère
qu'il va nous expliquer comment on va on
peut mettre fin à ça parce que ça ses
sensations qu'il explique sa balle
alors alors c'est pas un sujet marrant
non
bon la taille est ok
la prostitution est marrant absolument
pas tiens justement d'après son mari
britney spears est bisexuelle bonne
nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle jean-luc
alors paris avec sa mort
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un put encore plus drôle j'ai un
truc à tort
michèle alliot marie a déclaré avoir la
volonté nécessaire pour se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle l'empéri en la
non eh bien
c'est une femme qui a du caractère elle
est de droite évidemment ça moi je suis
pas mais c'est une femme qui a du
caractère
oui mais c'est le ministre de la défense
attention
pas spécialement spécialement lire
organise un colloque mondial pour
valider le négationnisme bonne nouvelle
mauvaise nouvelle
ouais c'est oui c'est répugnant c'est
terrible non c'est terrible s'il pouvait
garder faurisson cela dit ouais hein il
est là bas il est en stage qui reste
s'entraîne dans le salon déco soleil
alors ça ça ne vont pas revenir les
mains vides j'ai vu revenir et de
l'argent ils vont venir avec des moyens
ils vont c'est c'est tout ça et
effectivement tout à fait
inquiétant voilà très inquiétant le
journaliste denis robert mis en examen
dans l'affairé clearstream
c'est vraiment honteux
oui voilà ça s'appelle faire payer les
lampistes côté lui il a juste il a juste
mis sur la place ça sur la place
publique et 8 inquiéter les autres ce
n'est quelques chances et leur stream il
ya déjà cinq ans il a pas de moyens pour
bosser
il a une coupe de cheveux très aléatoire
et en plus il ya le faire chier pour ça
sans décote et lou d'olmert laisse
clairement entendre qu'israël possède la
bombe atomique
on sait depuis longtemps
zidane a souhaité mardi que l'algérie
redevienne la terre paisible qu'elle a
toujours été c'est bien dit dan sa bonne
nouvelle mais
non c'est bien qu'ils le disent
simplement se rappelle pas quand est-ce
que c'était paisible mais
mais c'est bien c'est bien moi je sais
qui
attendait chez mon pays donc je sais
quoi je parle ouais ouais ouais on a
appris à l'occasion de son procès que
jean luc lahaye n'avait pas 48 ans comme
disent ses biographies officielles mais
jeunes salle mais
non mais je l'avais interviewé il ya pas
mal d'années pour une station
radiophonique sur la base de 100 ciels
de naissance et donc je savais qu'il
trichait sur son âge a déjà un bon mois
laisse moi je trouve qu'il manque à la
télé ouais vous souvenez pas les
émissions qui présentait sur la
formidable c'est quand même le premier
mec qui apprenaient l'anglais en direct
alors si rien n'est fait contre le
réchauffement climatique en 2040
la bretagne est la cas marques seront
sous l'eau écoutez nous on a des
roulottes donc on se déplace à
depuis que marseille est à moins de
trois heures de paris en tgv il paraît
qu'il y pleut plus souvent nicolas
sarkozy voudrait interdire la
publication du petit nicolas pour
dénonciation calomnieuse
pour la première fois de sa carrière
jean paul belmondo aurait demandé doublé
par un cascadeur dans le lit de sa femme
les dernières paroles d'augusto pinochet
aurait été mieux dans ces castro qui a
gagné rebondissement dans la sphère
kennedy après avoir étudié l'hypothèse
d'un suicide le fbi s'orienterait
maintenant vers la thèse d'un banal
accident de voiture
[Musique]
on se retrouve après la pub
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bref
hu
m
bonjour
schwab romain hardy jean luc mélenchon
michel boujenah
yvan le bolloc'h
[Musique]
bon alors ils vendent leurs dollars avec
ma guitare s'appelle reviens et le
single s'appelle comment mika fait ça
fait comment ça fait mick harvey milk
fait mais tu sais si yannis qui est là
dans le coin
j'ai tué
mon truc et bien aimée pour l'instant
c'est rien
[Applaudissements]
minka pénitents envers les aînés
[Musique]
au péroné
li na est jamais coupé
mais jamais la paix
mais et j'avais coupé
quelle est
la vallée c'est plus qu'un mythe à
frites
oléron
en plus des revenus
année
m
et dans le monde
l'essai
jamais
barack obama
[Musique]
bonnet
paris
et
en mai
et quand
et
ouais
bon c
salut luis
[Applaudissements]
yvan lola gang maintenant il se met à la
musique gitane est ce que vous avez
commencé à voler vos premières poules
non mais attention maintenant les gitans
ils vont sur internet ils ont un
ordinateur yanis et ouais quand ils se
lèvent le matin ils louent son
ordinateur il compose des chansons
magnifiques vous pouvez retrouver dans
l'album ça changeait tout ça alors
breton gitans est ce que vous êtes
toujours fan d'audiard oui bien sûr bas
un des plus grands dialogues et du
cinéma français serait difficile de vous
faire un audiard quiz elle plaisir
attention on va jouer tous ensemble on
se concentre à l'est où et pour y
répondre on n'emmène pas des saucisses à
strasbourg quand on va à francfort ouais
on est rose sur la loi date un devis
pour aller quand les titres de 130 kilos
disent certaines choses c'est 70 ces
écoutes voilà
un pigeon c'est plus con qu'un dauphin
d'accord mais ça vole bien
la différence entre un conte le voleur
il y en a qui se repose non c'est pas ça
c'est comme la tendance à se reposer
quand on mettra les cons sur orbite n'en
a pas fini de tourner
la justice et comme la scène des arts
sont là voie pas de temps en temps on
n'y croit pas ouais le doute s'installe
si la connerie n'est pas remboursée par
les assurances sociales vous finirez sur
la paille bravo
[Applaudissements]
les cons ça ose tout
c'est comme ça qu'on les reconnaît voilà
sécurité chez les marins ce besoin de
faire des phrases
ça c'est juste quand francis blanche
marche sur la péniche et ventura mais
une grosse patate un marinier voilà dans
les tontons flingueurs moi quand on en
fait trop je collectionne plus je
disperse chantier jeu dynamite frappe
questions
aux quatre coins de paris qu' on va le
retrouver dispersé façon poehl
je suis pas lawrence d'arabie moi quand
je traverse le désert faut que je boive
ou un truc comme traverse pas le désert
sans boire ouais je vais leur envoyer
tout droit à la maison mais au terminus
des prétentieux à la
[Applaudissements]
alors j'imagine que tout le monde ici a
noté la la phrase désormais célèbre de
pascal sevran la [ __ ] des noirs est
responsable de la famine en afrique
superbe magnifique il faut la faire
encadrer je sais pas si la [ __ ] des
noirs responsable de la famine en
afrique mais la [ __ ] de pascal sevran
est responsable de beaucoup de déception
dans le show business
[Applaudissements]
on voit rarement des noirs à la chance
aux chansons je pensais à ça c'est vrai
c'est plutôt des mines et blandine et à
la chasse aux chansons non mais il doit
prendre des danseurs noirs c'est dommage
mais si on peut plus être raciste quand
on bosse sur france 2 c'est difficile
pour laurent gerra quand il fait ses
choux en direct de lyon le samedi soir
ça va
tu es content d'être sur canal+ non
ravit
encore quand la juste différence de
traitement il ya un mec qui s'appelle
dieudonné il a fait il a dit le tiers 2
à 1 il a été boycottée par toutes les
chaînes de télé aujourd'hui on ne voit
nulle part et pascal sevran la semaine
prochaine vous le verrez tous les jours
à la télévision jour là bien sûr
ce
qui est injuste c'est pas le premier cas
c'est le deuxième ce qui est injuste
c'est que pascal souvent soit pas
vraiment sanctionné et toutes les façons
il va être attaqué en justice je pense
mais j'ai lu qu'il y avait des
organisations qui l'attaquent en justice
il va être condamné et il va traîner ça
à mon avis pendant des années et il est
mal barrés le mec opus est un homme
public à sa manière il a une
responsabilité énorme qu'il est très
connu il passe beaucoup la télé c'est
c'est incroyable que ce mec puisse dire
des choses pareilles et qu'on le laisse
non il faut qu'ils soient punis où
qu'ils soient punis pascal sevran
est d'accord oui bien sûr bien sûr il ya
mis les formes c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire ouais moi je suis pas
mécontent qu'il soit soutient nicolas
sarkozy et je le rappelle mais il ya des
objets déco il ya une super écuries eu
des gagnants il ya des mineurs avec
nicolas
[Applaudissements]
attention s'il fait son gouvernement
pareil ça va par exemple est jouable
alors heureusement pascal sevran s'est
excusé voici les cinq plus mauvaises
excuses de pascal sevran j'ai dit que la
ligue des noirs responsable de la famine
en afrique pardon je voulais dire
responsable du tsunami en asie
comme si vous n'aviez jamais été jaloux
de la [ __ ] des noirs
je n'ai jamais dit la [ __ ] des noirs
responsable de la famine en afrique j'ai
dit l'habite des [ __ ] et responsable
la famine en afrique excusez moi mais
c'est quand même pas un mec qui a écrit
il venait d'avoir 18 ans
c'est pas moi c'est georges frêche
[Musique]
alors y'a un truc qui va faire plaisir à
pascal sevran c'est la baisse de la
fertilité dans le monde 50 % de
spermatozoïdes en moi en 50 ans un
couple sur cinq n'arrive pas à faire des
bébés pendant
alors jean pierre coffe nous signale
encore quelques producteurs indépendants
qui font du sperme de qualité à
l'ancienne est parfaite mère industriel
qu'on nous serve partout on regarde et
on en parle après
voilà une nouvelle qui va vous mettre
les olives en raisins de corinthe
figurez vous que nos spermatozoïdes sont
intoxiqués par les produits chimiques en
l'espace de 2-3 génération le taux de
spermatozoïdes a baissé de moitié chez
le mâle européen résultat aujourd'hui
boucle sur cère n'arrive plus avoir
d'enfant certaines substances
dangereuses sont déjà identifiés comme
les phtalates le tcp ou le bisphénol a
je vous voyais pas quand vous mettez un
coup de lave glace et que ça sent bon
dans la voiture eh ben vous faites du
mal à votre père matteo vide les
industriels utilisent cent mille
produits chimiques différents si bien
dans les textiles les produits nettoyage
les peintures des appareils électriques
or seuls 3000 de ces substances ont été
testés pour évaluer leur dangerosité à
la limite ça tue des frissons en slip
heureusement l'europe est là et lance le
projet reach ici 2018 trente mille
nouveaux produits chimiques devront être
testés en laboratoire au frais des
industriels trente mille sur 100000
forcément il y en a qui trouvent que ce
n'est pas assez on estime que sont plus
de 15 mille d'entre elles on connaîtra
pas justement cette capacité à tafer
recaro production mais ce qui fait
flipper dans cette histoire c'est que
bientôt tous les européens mal pourrait
ressembler à pascal sevran des vieux
bonhomme aux couilles flapi qui voudrait
juste stériliser l'autre moitié de la
planète franchement faudrait pas arrêté
de se quitter la glace
voilà alors est ce la fin de la race
humaine michel boujenah mais non
monsieur on va en continu à s'envoyer en
l'air on va faire des enfants sur le
5800 qu'on fasse attention c'est tout à
bas à bas oui voilà c'est tout
il faut pas trop s'entraîner
pétition faut y aller direct ça vous
inquiète vous ça là on vient de dire il
ya cent mille produits chimiques qui
entrent qui sont prévues en europe
trente mille sont considérés comme
devant être observé les 70000 on n'en
parle plus sur les trente mille en
question le le représentant qu'on a vue
d'une ong a dit à bernac 13000 qui vont
être examinés cent mille trente mille
13me attend ce n'est pas fini là dessus
sur ce total là il y en a mille cinq
cents qui sont considérés par la
commission comme entre guillemets
extrêmement préoccupant c'est à dire que
vraiment là ça craint 1 d'accord ils
sont cancérigènes saah sah diminue notre
espérance de vie tout quoi vraiment du
poison et basques eux mêmes sur ses 1500
là on a décidé qu'il n'y aurait que 10%
ou nouvelles obligations l'obligation de
les remplacer quentin produits
alternatifs existent à dire vous avez un
produit dangereux et un produit
alternatif et ben y'a que dans 10 % des
cas qu'on est obligé de prendre le
brevet relatif donc je pense que le le
commissaire européen le gars qui
s'occupait ça est très content parce
qu'il a enfin règlement ouf c'est
toujours ça de pris mais quand même
franchement il ya des gens qui se
comportent et continuent à se comporter
avec des oeillères qui ne voient pas le
danger ou qui ne veulent pas le voir
parce qu'il s'en fiche parce que c'est
la concurrence libre et non faussée et
chacun profite voilà c'est ça le fond de
la sphère qui est toujours la même
logique 1 ou bien on fait tout de suite
ses affaires et puis on ramasse ah oui
on dit bah c'est bien comme ça le
capitalisme jean-luc sabawi mais c'est
vous qui l'avez dire
oui mais le capitalisme on peut aussi y
mettre des règles on peut aussi il faut
que tous ces gens acceptent de
comprendre que tout n'est pas permis que
ce con carne l'on gagné moins d'argent
ah bah oui mais c'est plus le
capitalisme alors c'est moins d'argent
si les c'est vous qui l'aurait dit
resavacs ici l'ambiance et la belle
d'accord ballon dans ce cas là font
mieux que ça c'est ce nom oui bon ben
voilà il se faisait la révolution la
question pensent trop vite et 8h15 non
non non ridiculiser pas les grandes
idées mais non
et on peut
ces gens sérieux je sais j'en avais je
vous respecte du monde mon coeur c'est
ce que j'ai lu non mais je n'ai je vous
jure que en aucun cas c'est une manière
de tourner en dérision vous avez dit
c'est très grave si noyau de personnes
qui décident que du point de vue de
leurs affaires et des profits qu'ils
doivent rentrer il met sciemment en
danger la vie de tous leurs
contemporains en se disant c'est pas mon
problème que les autres c'est plus que
mettre en danger la vie des
contemporains ce qui aura plus
contemporain ce salon est tous d'accord
c'est pour dire que cette question-là de
l'écologie on ne peut plus la traiter
comme on l'a eue traité à d'autres
moments où on pouvait dire on ne savait
pas et je me mets dans le jeu mais dans
le cas où ou peut-être je n'avais pas
une pleine conscience d'une jambe à la
question ça vous inquiète cette fin
probable de la race humaine à cause des
jouets pour enfants
non mais à cause de tous les produits la
drôme et surtout ce qu'est ce qui est ce
qui est quand même sidérant c'est que ça
fait au moins une quarantaine d'années
que les écologistes mettent en gare avec
aucun gouvernement nulle part dans le
monde les a écoutés c'est seulement
maintenant que on commence à avoir une
audience grâce à nicolas hulot entre
autres c'est surtout quand tu vois
qu'ils arrivent neige sur le toit du
moins depuis seulement sept libanais
contre les autres ce soit quand on vous
dit que vous êtes très malade également
souvenez vous il ya vingt ans il y avait
un mec ça peyronnet du moins jeunes avec
un sous pull aux touristes et wade est
grotesque c'est un don il fait de aux
élections et une rien disait naguère
t'es bien gentil allez dégagez ben
aujourd'hui il avait raison et justement
cette semaine pas de vacances pour
monsieur hulot l'autre nico de la
campagne a rencontré sarko et ségo pour
obtenir des engagements sérieux de leur
part au sujet de son pacte écologique
et sinon il se présentera sinon il va se
présenter au vote auriez pour un mec qui
est coiffée comme marie george buffet
après
on regarde on en parle
la police ne nous montre pas seulement
des images elle les fabrique et croyez
moi c'est pas toujours simple surtout
quand tous les cameramans de paris sont
sur le coup pour filmer une simple
poignée de main ségolène félin génie on
se connaît déjà et puis soudain ça
s'accélère
[Musique]
normalement c'était une séance de
travail qui avait vocation à se faire
dans la discrétion mais dites moi on
serait pas en train de manipuler se
demande nicolas maintien juste le temps
pour ségolène d'enlever sa doudoune de
se recoiffer elle est prête pour la
photo
[Musique]
une photo pareil c'est quand même la
preuve que ségolène et écolo enfin aussi
écolo que bayrou sarkozy chirac tous
ceux qui sont fait prendre en photo avec
nicolas dans cette société on peut rien
obtenir par la voie de la raison et qui
font toujours l'obtenir par la voie de
la pression forcément avec 87%
d'opinions favorables nicolas hulot a de
quoi faire pression et du coup il s'est
fait plein de nouveaux amis mais là où
il comptera vraiment ses nouveaux amis
c'est s'il se décide à se présenter à la
présidentielle bon ben si l'écologie
veut en profiter on va on va pas se
priver voilà pas de vacances de monsieur
hulot il a plein de boulot cette semaine
oui c'est votre idole là j'ai
l'impression là je serai conditionnelle
c'est un fait que l'écologie depuis très
longtemps est la priorité des priorités
on commence seulement à en prendre
conscience grâce à des gens comme lui et
toi tu veux très pauvre il aussi se
présenter ou s'ils se présentent et oui
oui oui oui oui c'est très très
important de je pense pas qu'ils
passeraient je pense je pense qu'ils qui
pèserait lourd dans la balance a eu au
premier tour lui donner du poids c'est
très important est indiscutablement
important
qu'ils allaient faire alors vous la lame
échanger libéral avec ça non mais moi je
suis de gauche domine votre et à gauche
quand ça veut pas dire juteux que je
méprise qui dit tout au contraire que ça
fait progresser dans les esprits l'idée
d'un intérêt général par n'a vécu une
période d' égoïsme forcené chacun pour
soi et puis que les autres crèvent et je
pense que ça ça nous permet de re
comprendre à quel point on est tous liés
les uns aux autres par l'air par l'opah
ru a tout cédé rien voilà et donc une
certaine
pardon si je vous choque mais c'est une
prime au collectivisme ce qui fait la
solidarité ce qu'on a en commun
oui oui je sais je suis écouté
enfin il faut juste du collectivisme
n'ont
fait bien attention nicolas hulot parce
que il a quand même fort soutenu jacques
chirac qui vous récompenser a fait les
essais nucléaires
alors si nicolas hulot est élu il ya
cinq changements promis françoise vous
serez heureux de l'apprendre premières
mesures d'urgence des passages cloutés
pour les serbes sur les autoroutes le
trou de la sécu sera bouché avec des
branches d'arbres
on créera un couloir de voiture sur le
bord de la chaussée
les possesseurs de 4,4 seront émasculé
par un pélican
suis en pierre foucault se prépare
psychologiquement pour 2012
[Musique]
alors on va voir s'il est prêt à signer
le pacte écologique de nicolas hulot on
va faire un écolo quiz qui recycle ses
déchets à moi toi très bien que voulant
vélo je roule en gpl
qui pense l éteindre la lumière en
quittant voir
les veilles aussi assez bien c'est bien
qu'ils évitent de laisser couler l'eau
en se lavant les dents
toi tu aimes pas le
dakar qui ne tirent plus sa chasse d'eau
qu'une fois par semaine
attendez on peut être écolo ou par mail
en son nom c'est pas bien et chasse
d'eau à deux vitesses a existé c'est
vrai
qui prend que des douches bah moi mais
j'ai pas de m
c'est pour ça qu'on joue d'un gitan et
joue de la guitare et son espace
camille des panneaux solaires sur son
toit mois mais ouais mais moi j'ai un
bon j'ai une caravane qui éteint le
moteur de sa voiture dans les descentes
ça super risque c'est super équipe à ce
que sa coupe la direction assistée et
les freins n'essayez pas ça qui coupe
son moteur les embouteillages non parce
qu'ils utilisent une chèvre dans son
jardin plutôt calme désarmant
jean-luc t'as pas une seul site web non
mais je vais y penser la france et sa
femme en fonction des ténèbres qui
refusent les sacs plastique dans les
magasins
ben maintenant il n'est plus enfin je
sais pas si tu vas chez chez leclerc tu
achètes un gros sac et il garde toute ta
vie c'est bien mais faut aller faire ses
courses et riz qui porte ses sous
vêtements plusieurs jours de suite pour
éviter les lessives jean-luc n'ont pas
tellement écolo finalement
qui a refusé de semis permet qu'il y ait
ce soir pour protéger les baleines
qui va rentrer ce soir en bus plutôt
qu'en taxi non c'est vrai bien métro
toujours le métro mais bien sûr c'est ce
qui va le plus vite c'est ce qui est le
plus sympa c'est ce qui marche le mieux
le reste vous êtes là bloqué partout
alors le métro le rer le bus il revient
aussi
[Musique]
et
oui non c'est pas du baratin et la
liberté ça c'est très bon ça
[Applaudissements]
ségolène royal et le soin au 20 heures
elle est élue ouais c'est tout moi
qui a déjà mis du déodorant ushuaïa
n'ont jamais j'avais besoin de théodore
en moi je me sens très bon être dans la
salle mais fiat avec les déodorants
ouais ah oui bah oui il ya du phtalate
dedans ça de fitness lia moi j'ai pas
dire du mal de nicolas
qui baissent dans le noir
simon zenke d'électricité soir le le
noir noir noir absolu ça n'existe pas
parce qu'au bout d'un moment tu
t'habitues un peu comme ça il ya
toujours des lumières qui viennent de
l'extérieur et si tu es bien concentré
tu vois quelqu'un
[Rires]
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs stéphane guillon
stéphane bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
politique après la couverture de
paris-match dédiée à nicolas sarkozy
intitulé un destin en marche d'autres
couverture d'une neutralité exemplaires
sont à l'étude le géant au coeur tendre
l'idole des banlieues le prince charmant
de cécilia à propos de cécilia le même
magazine écrit derrière un physique de
star se cache une subtile conseillère il
y a un an la subtile conseillère se
cacher aux états unis dans les bras d'un
publicitaire une info paris match depuis
le directeur de l'époque pointe aux
assedic bien fait en russie à l'heure
qu'il est il serait chose
[Applaudissements]
politique toujours d'après le figaro
ségolène est plus écolo que hulot c'est
vrai à la maison ségolène fait très
gaffe pour économiser la lessive
françois hollande ne met que des
bermudas
économie enfin une vraie mesure sociale
l'état veut améliorer le classement des
palaces on pourrait passer de 4 étoile à
5 étoiles luxe cela dit au niveau des
campings il ya encore des améliorations
celui ci est au pied de beaubourg c'est
très centrale par rapport à un camping
en bordure de périphérique je mettrai
une étoile en plus de
sociétés un sondage hyper intéressant du
parisien nous apprend que 23% d'entre
nous rêvent de réveillonner avec mimie
mathy faire gaffe quand même qu'elles
repartent pas avec le déguisement des
enfants
pascal sevran pascal sevran garde son
boulot à france 2 mme écope d'un
avertissement vienne vraie éthique sur
le service public refusé d'abandonner la
présentation d'une émission sur paris
première vous êtes viré en revanche si
vous dites la [ __ ] des noirs est
responsable de la famine en afrique on
vous garde cela dit un avertissement à
france 2 ça ne rigole pas au bout du 3e
pascal pourrait perdre sa place de
parking
[Applaudissements]
on n'en est pas là dimanche dans son
émission pascal a chanté avec patrick
bruel que reste-t-il de nos amours pas
grand chose quand on a stérilisé la
moitié de la planète
après l'élection miss france prix du
bébé cadum 2007 pour gagner il devait
être joufflu potelé lustré et rayonnant
donc tout ce qui était bébé congelé
noyer brûlé c'est pas la peine la
société picard réfléchit à un concours
parallèle
sport
championnats d'europe consécration pour
laure manaudou
vingt ans après l'échec du petit grégory
dans la vologne lors réconcilie la
france avec la natation
humanitaire deux ans après le tsunami 30
% des dons seulement ont été
redistribuées natacha amal qui dans la
catastrophe avait perdu une paire de
tongs pradhan toujours pas été
indemnisés
moi c'est la dernière fois que je donne
t-il
on termine par une lettre d'un
téléspectateur après l'élection d'une
miss sourde aura-t-on une miss aveugle
non on voit le blanc des yeux c'est
moche
faut que le handicap reste esthétique
dernière minute on vient de l'apprendre
dionis s'installe en suisse alors
bientôt l'organisation d'un suisse ton
pour aider les jeunes artistes qui
chantent ici à aller s'installer en
suisse comme aznavour patricia kaas ou
marie laforêt à la semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
on
passe au zapping
[Musique]
michel boujenah la dernière fois qu'ils
s'étaient vus c'était à l'occasion d'un
spectacle qui s'appelait rire contre le
racisme alors le bilan qu'a gagner
on a le rire n'a pas encore gagné mais
c'est bien que cette manifestation
existe chaque année au zénith et c'est
bien que de plus en plus de gens y
participent du maurice y participent
alors on parle d'un rire contre les 35
heures c'est
je ne suis pas au courant de ça bien
alors pour le moment on va vous jouer
les nouveaux magnifiques sur scène qui
est aussi disponible en dvd un beau
cadeau de noël aussi ça fera trois
cadeaux aujourd'hui alors c'est la suite
des magnifiques évidemment c'est
toujours les aventures de maxo julot et
biggie les éternels papy tunisien vingt
ans après alors aujourd'hui il parle de
la contraception de la fécondation in
vitro et ils sont pas content mais ils
comprennent pas assez tôt ici
comprennent pas ça veut dire que quand
la plaie de la petite fille qui avait 16
ans parle à sa grand mère simone
boutboul qui a 85 ans et qui lui dit à
16 ans je comprends pas si j'ai maîtrisé
le rapport de transfert que j'avais pas
pourquoi mon père avec vincent qu'ils
sont copains elle lui dit y compris l
effet je l'attends que je mélange les
mots pour qu'ils reviennent en ordre
non ils sont voilà ils sont confrontés
au monde d'aujourd'hui c'est des
personnages que j'adore ils servent de
deux prismes de miroirs déformants
je les adore je les adore mais c'est
triste vous savez bien que j'ai toujours
du mal à parler de mes spectacles on va
regarder alors
y'a pas de papa papa ya pas de papa papa
tu dis ça parce qu'il va pas me plaire
non papa il n'y a pas de papa je les
fais une vie trop in vitro
c'est un italien
comment il s'appelle giuseppe in vitro
miquel et in vitro mais mais non papa tu
comprends pas c'est une fécondation in
vitro je les fais tout seul j'ai pas eu
besoin d'hommes pour faire cet enfant tu
comprends pas c'est mon bébé à moi tout
seul j'ai pas eu besoin d'hommes non je
comprends qu'on joue et c'est à dire que
nous les hommes déjà on savait pas grand
chose sur les enfants mais n'ont servi à
rien comme ça c'est réglé vers 72 heures
sont restés en bas de chez elle 72
heures en dépression nerveuse appuyez
sur le réverbère 72 heures comme ça
j'étais comme ça comme ça je secoue et
les graines comme ça
comme ça j'en disais arrêter
l'entraînement ce pas la peine arrêté
arrêté on est au chômage technique c'est
pas la peine
on a été délocalisée c'est pas la faire
nous sommes ouverts
et nous mêmes cuit sur scène et or dvd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le sujet people de la semaine à par
marie drucker et son ministre si johnny
qui est partie s'installer en suisse à
gstaad
alors johnny soutient sarkozy par en
suisse imaginez ce qu'ils ne soutiennent
pas
johnny c'est avant tout un mystère
comment ce gros beauf ringard fringué
comme un cow boy des fêtes foraines peut
plaire à la france entière les hommes
politiques ça les rend complètement
dingue lyrique même parfois je veux vous
redonner ce qu'on vous a fait perdre de
plus précieux cher johnny l'envié
d'avoir envie
et
et quand notre petit napoléon pas ses
troupes en revue dans le protocole il
mais johnny devant françois fillion son
futur premier ministre enfin quand on
voit la tête de son gynécologue on dit
que tout est possible et puis voilà que
jenny décide d'aller payer ses impôts en
suisse comme
alors on se dit que ça va le rendre
impopulaire qu'on peut et critiquer mais
il ya ce mystère jenny alors plutôt que
de faire dans connement 10 % dans les
sondages d'un coup le gouvernement
décide de prendre ça à la cool l'herbe
du voisin est toujours plus verte que la
sienne jusqu'à ce qu'on s'aperçoive que
c'est du gazon artificiel
en revanche au ps françois hollande
n'est pas loin de traiter johnny de
mauvais français ça c'est très
intéressant parce que si pour être un
bon français il suffit de payer ses
impôts en france eh bien tous les
travailleurs d'émigrés qui payent leurs
impôts en france sont de bons français
on en déduit donc que le ps compte
donner le droit de vote aux étrangers
sauf qu'au ps ces programmes qui décide
alors françoise ça nous a dit vous à un
moment de votre vie de partir vous
installez ensuite vous avez pensé à ça
jamais jamais non mais là je pense que
s'il est allé s'installer en suisse
c'est parce que sarkozy lui a dit que sa
cause était perdue à lui ça
que la gauche allait passer bizarre non
le mec il défend sarkozy par an si ce
moment où l'autre il est président ça va
peut-être raison non mais bon il faut
bien faire la part allouée l'artiste on
peut pas sans moi je fais partie de ceux
qui aiment c'est une sur aprilia ses
opinions c'est autre chose l'égalité
n'est pas d'accord et puis après il ya
un comportement personnel et ce qu'il
fait là c'est nul c'est nabeul 1 c'est
minable parce qu'il s'agit de sommes
d'argent considérables cet homme n'a
besoin de rien il a déjà tout oui c'est
triste d'avoir autant d'argent égalité
en suisse on peut revenir sur la dream
team de nicolas sarkozy j'aime bien
alors donc johnny hallyday le mec qui
gagne plein de pognon qui se barre en
sus sont pas payer d'impôts pascal
sevran le mec qui a un qui sait qu'il ya
d'autres encore gynéco et stevie voilà
j'aimerais bien qu'on dise qu'ils
appelèrent sarkozy va rappeler line
renaud et du teil recruteur je pense le
rester plus calme avec eux mais toute
façon quoi qu'ils fassent johnny il sera
les gens ils passeront tout je crois pas
la conversion ce sont d'abord les gens
leur demande pas leur avis c'est l'outil
regarder ces dix pensent ils se disent
se fout de nous et ça n'empêche pas
d'aimer ce qui produit un comme artiste
mais ce qu'il fait est méprisable c'est
méprisable parce que c'est un mauvais
exemple et après on va nous dire quand
on viendra dans les débats
parlementaires dire bah là il faut
augmenter les impôts vont dire ah mais
si vous faites ça il vous tous s'en
aller c'est à dire qu'on prend prétexte
des turpitudes
email mais attendez
alors pour les inciter à rester faut
leur passer tous leurs caprices faut
qu'ils payent rien et en plus ce qu'on
leur demande s'il vous plaît vous voulez
bien rester pour marcher sur la tête ça
c'est pas possible tout le monde doit
participer et puis plus on est riche
mais plus on participe non j'ai mieux
comme ça non bien sûr non seulement le
pays où les riches sont le plus imposé
en europe non pas du tout bien puisque
antique la glace héritiers paye des
droits de succession 13 et bien tant
mieux mais moi je vais avoir pleuré pour
eux mais bien sûr
c'est une liste mérignac iphone quel
guerrier j'y vois moi j'ai pas rien je
vais pas vous jouer la comédie un jeu
n'est pas rien mais je trouve anormal
que quand on a beaucoup on ne veuille
pas partagé au point d'aller courir se
cacher dans un actif à payer toute votre
vie en en gagnant des sommes importantes
kankan pendant 40 ans vous avez payé 60
% plus très bien de ce qui va tomber
c'est quoi ta soif mais oui bah oui les
masques et celui qui n'a eu celui qui a
tiré la langue toute sa vie celui là il
fait quoi le gers ida ou se cacher on
lui doit les payer autant d'impôts
pendant tant d'années de plus envers les
continentaux mais quand on peut mais les
gens qui ont pas beaucoup d'argent qui
ont travaillé toute leur vie pour avoir
une maison oui et qui met sur les zones
exemptes et les gens c'est un guerrier
un plafond aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
à partir d'une certaine somme on
commence à payer en dessous non là c'est
à peu près un million la maison 1
million et 1 million de francs oui oui
de france 2 france 2 les maisons à
migron on a payé ses impôts toute sa vie
oui moi je suis pour paie des impôts et
j'en paye
j'aimerais savoir une chose comment
expliquer que c'est trop mais si je
travaille toute ma vie et donc je paye
mes impôts quand je paye mes impôts
l'argent qui me reste dans ma poche il
est à moi sur l'héritage oui ch comprend
pas que si j'ai travaillé toute ma vie
pour m'acheter une maison par exemple au
moins ma maison je parle pas du nom
devenu une usine votre maison non mais
je parle pas d'une non mais moi je vois
plein de gens qui ont travaillé toute
leur vie je parle avec des artistes qui
ont eu des bonnes passes dans leur vie
qui est bon ils ont acheté une maison
ils ont paysans paie les impôts et tout
ça et puis le travail a moins bien
marché ils ont quand même réussi à
garder leur maison et quand y meurent
les enfants ils sont obligés de vendre
la maison qui est leur maison dans
laquelle ils ont vécu et il se retrouve
à être obligé de la vendre pour payer
les droits de succession
ce que je veux dire c'est que ce que je
veux dire c'est que entre payer des
droits de succession sur une usine bien
sûr je peux quoi à la demie je peux
comprendre mais une maison mais une
maison la mise sous sa maison soit
gentil
moi j'arrivais leçons et sa maison j'ai
réglé le col et moi j'ai mis de côté les
droits de succession et j'ai payé les
impôts dessus j'ai fait tout le parti et
ma maison tu peux pas me l'enlever tu
m'arrive casta désaccord mais excuse moi
ça c'est la droite
c'est chirac et sarkozy et je ne vis pas
imagine quand ça sera
pour cent n'avaient d'abord faut tout
d'abord on doit rappeler à tout le monde
une chose quand on paye des impôts ça
revient de dire ça savions bien
collectif normalement oui j'ai envie
d'accord mais c'est déjà pas mal parce
que j'ai entendu c'est bien qu'autour de
ce plateau soit tous d'accord parce que
le nombre de gens que j'ai entendu
pleurer sur les impôts l'an manière
irresponsable quand je dis pas de nom
mais beaucoup de gens vraiment c'est
énorme c'est sans sa femme après ya la
question de la maison clame la maison de
non pas moi mais je mets le type il a
travaillé tout c'est quand même
sa maison et arrêté de fermeture et que
l'impôt est confiscatoire en france
c'est pas vrai bon il ya un niveau de
patrimoine en dessous duquel on ne paye
pas d'impôts il faut il faut quand même
le savent à pierre-ratte en écart non
c'est pas un battant c'est ben oui quand
tu as la petite maison dont il parle
elle est pratiquement exempte et après
il ya le principe de savoir si on paye
non sur l'héritage alors après c'est un
choix en effet c'est un choix moi je
choisis qu'on paye beaucoup sur
l'héritage voilà je pense que d'une
génération à l'autre bien sûr on est de
ses enfants qu'est ce qui fait bouger
n'at il a payé il a mis des sous de côté
ils vont avoir la maison et l'héritage
et est payé d'avancé une manière
d'organiser sa fortune pour le reste moi
je trouve que chaque génération bien sûr
profit de
0,01 sagerpar
aujourd'hui ils en sont avec un million
de francis laborde est en avance ou ya
dix ans dans la rue ont terminé que
tissent face de la semaine alors qui a
dit qui a dit ça va mal en irak saddam
hussein
kenza du loft philippe douste-blazy ou
george bush philippe douste-blazy
george bush hoarau qui a dit les
chasseurs participent à la défense de
l'environnement et à la protection de la
nature oui oui ça m'étonne pas
cette semaine ils étaient emballés avec
des chasseurs donc du coup
qui a dit je ne peux pas me plaindre mon
épouse me dit souvent tu l'as voulu tu
là françois hollande dominique de
villepin véronique zidane ou
l'inspecteur columbo
colombo sa 403 on a lancé villepin bon
désolé
qui a dit tu vois j'en suis arrivé à
espérer que ségolène royal reste
présidente de poitou charentes françois
hollande laurent fabius jean pierre
raffarin ou michel de café du commerce à
part
qui a dit je serai un des vainqueurs de
la campagne présidentielle et je serai
au second tour béroud banon nicolas
dupont aignan jean marie le pen philippe
de villiers jean luc mélenchon
[Rires]
de villiers de villiers
tu imagines de villiers au second tour
face à le pen
à la maison je peux dire que la vente
directe
tu veux te pour qu'il y ait vivier
l'open où la plupart en suisse et johnny
habitacle
moi je pars de l'autre côté qui a dit le
loup est un loup pour l'homme
michèle alliot marie
michèle alliot marie françoise de
panafieu nadine morano ou doc gynéco le
loup est un loup pour l'homme
françoise de panafieu qui est dit le
terme de sous-hommes est sorti sous la
colère je voulais dire minus ou minable
jean georges frêche georges frêche à
propos des harkis absolument qui a dit
va te faire [ __ ] au premier ministre
australien
george bush a non elton john ou un combo
voilà c'est ça c'est elton john elton
john parce que le soin ministre
australien et
l'homosexuel mais les australiens ils
ont vraiment des problèmes je veux dire
les blancs 1 ouais ils ont vraiment des
problèmes avec leur système de pensée
oui j'ai remarqué plusieurs fois
que j'ai un cahier sur les australiens
qui a dit nous devons aujourd'hui nous
féliciter de ce que les empreintes
génétiques stocker permettent déjà
d'élucider beaucoup plus d'affaires que
le fichier des empreintes génitales
c'est
jean françois copé
il ya des ségolène royal souris
tellement que j'ai l'impression que son
programme ccdh dans
ça c'est bon nicolas sarkozy philippe de
villiers laurent fabius ou joey starr
un truc méprisant
et méprisable s'y passait pas ces
bateaux shebab je crois enfin parce que
c'est joey starr
salut l'intérieur merci bonsoir
parenthèse michel boujenah les nouveaux
mami lui sur scène et en cdd
son centre est en level up
l'album s'appelle ma guitare s'appelle
revient voilà je vous laisse avec les
amis de groland et je me retrouve bien
semaine prochaine merci de votre
fidélité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu